I want to review a little bit of what we
did in the last video and maybe draw
larger more spread-out diagram because I
think in the last video I started to
cram things on the right-hand side here
and this is a very important concept so
I wanted to do it nice and spread out in
a way that we can breathe and maybe in
the process I can fill in some more
blanks so let's go back and draw the
membrane of a thylakoid that's sitting
inside of a chloroplast I'm going to
draw the same membrane here so let me
draw it nice and spread out so let me
draw a nice big membrane like that and
that's the inside of the membrane so you
can imagine that this loops around and
that would form the thylakoid on this
side of the membrane we have the lumen
and on the outside of the membrane we
have the stroma all the fluid that fills
up the chloroplast so this is the stroma
right there and this is just a kind of a
standard membrane that we see in a lot
of organelles but this is actually a
membrane within an organelle and it
might be a little be a phospho by lipid
layer and I just talked about I just say
that or I'm pointing that out because I
want to think a little bit about in this
video how protons can actually get
across this thing you know how do we use
the energy from these electrons going to
lower energy states to actually pump
protons across this membrane so you know
when you have these by lipid layers your
outside is hydrophilic and it of course
it'll you know it is hydrophilic because
it operates well in a polar environment
and then the insides are nonpolar or
they're hydrophobic and you have these
tails so I could draw the whole membrane
like that but I won't do that it'll take
me forever but let me draw some of the
components that I did in the last video
so we have these complexes that span
across this membrane and the place that
we started off with was the photosystem
2 complex
photo system 2 and then later on we have
the photosystem one complex photosystem
1 complex and let me draw the ATP
synthase right here so ATP synthase also
spans across it then it has this little
remoter part of it and you know the
hydrogens go through and spins the motor
and it crams the phosphate groups into
the ADP to make ATP but I'll talk about
that in a second but the first thing I
want to point out is as I said in the
last video the first place where the
electrons get excited the firt is in the
chlorophyll and photosystem ii and then
it gets less and less and less excited
it gets handed off from one complex to
another complex and eventually ends up
in photosystem one it gets excited again
then it gets handed off headed off the
whole time that energy is being used to
transfer hydrogen protons from the
stroma from the stroma into the lumen
into the lumen but the first question
that you know I would ask is why is this
called photosystem ii while this is
called photosystem one where we're
starting over here and the reason is
this was discovered first this was
discovered first even though in the
light reaction it actually comes into
use or it comes into play second this
was discovered first so that's why they
call it photosystem one but the reality
is photosystem two is where everything
starts from now in some textbooks you'll
also see this written as p680 and you'll
see photosystem one written as p700 and
these numbers come from the wavelength
of light that is best absorbed by the
chlorophyll in these photosystems so 680
corresponds to 680 nanometers that's the
wavelength of light that this absorbs
the best 700 corresponds to 700
nanometers that's the wavelength of
light it absorbs best now what I want to
do here is draw a little diagram below
here to kind of talk more about the
electron energy States I just kind of
hand waved it a little bit in the last
video so I'm going to draw a little
diagram here a little diagram here and
over here I'm going to write the
different things that the electron can
be a part of so right now let's say the
electron could be part of h2o it could
be part of it could be a part of
chlorophyll a chlorophyll
so a it could be a part of I'll talk
more about this in a little bit
vo vo fight in and then I could and then
you have all the molecules that it can
get over the complexes it can become
part of I'll actually write them down
here so let me write I don't want to
take up too much space plasto Quinn own
Quinn own and then there's a cytochrome
b6f complex so I'll just write B 6f b 6f
then you have plastocyanin plasto sign
and i'll just write it as pc you don't
have to memorize these unless you have
you know you'll forget them in a week if
you do but unless you're you know you're
studying photosynthesis then it might
make sense to memorize them and this is
in photosystem two photosystem two then
you have chlorophyll in photosystem one
chlorophyll in photosystem one and then
you have some other you know you have
for ferredoxin I'll just write F D for
ferredoxin some other molecules you keep
going and then you have your eventual
electron acceptor nadp+ which once it
accepts the electron becomes NADPH nad
pH now electrons are very so this is you
know if we go up that's a high energy
state down as a low energy State
so electrons are already very
comfortable very comfortable in water
and in chlorophyll a they're even more
comfortable at least this is how I view
it they're even more comfortable but so
left to its own devices you know this
electron will never leave chlorophyll a
but we know what happens a photon comes
in from 93 million miles away and it can
imagine photons as little light packets
or you can view as the light wave either
way and it excites you know it excites
not necessarily directly the chlorophyll
a it might excite other other antennae
chlorophyll or other pigment molecules
and then through resonance energy you
can imagine them vibrating and
eventually will excite the chlorophyll a
dreck
or excite the electrons in chlorophyll a
directly and this dude right here gets
excited so it goes let me do that in a
in a brighter color so it goes to a high
energy state so the electron here is in
a high energy State ignore that lumen
right there it has nothing to do with
this electron and then it goes and
actually when it goes to the high energy
state maybe I should draw it like this
it actually shows up in pheophytin that
is the primary electron acceptor and
it's actually a chlorophyll a molecule
and I'll actually let me show you what a
chlorophyll a molecule looks like this
is what a chlorophyll a molecule looks
like and in general it has a hydrocarbon
tail you see that right here hydrocarbon
tail hydrocarbon tail and it has a
porphyrin ring or porphyrin head I guess
you could call it porphyrin head this
little group right here is called a
porphyrin poor foreign head and right in
the center of it you have a magnesium
that green right there that's a
magnesium ion and when the photon comes
in or when the resonance energy comes in
from some of the antenna molecules
electrons in the double bond sitting
here in the porphyrin head get excited
those are the electrons that we're
talking about and they get excited in
the first electron acceptor is this feel
fighting that I just talked about
pheophytin it actually looks just like a
chlorophyll but it has no magnesium ion
in this in the middle and maybe I'm
getting a little bit into the weeds a
little bit too much but the feel
fighting actually see in this diagram
right here it's part of this photosystem
complex so the electron you can imagine
it jumping from the chlorophyll to the
pheophytin that does not have that does
not have that magnesium in the center
and once it's in the few fighting it's
at a very very very very high energy
state it's at a very high energy state
and then it keeps being transferred from
the field fighting it it goes to the
plastic win tone so maybe we go to a
slightly lower energy state here let me
keep using the electron in green then it
keeps going to a slightly lower energy
state in the cytochrome b6f comp
flex and then you have the plastocyanin
complex lower energy state and then
eventually it goes into into photosystem
one at a even lower energy state maybe
slightly higher than the energy state
that it was originally in the
chlorophyll a molecule in photosystem
two another photon or another set of
photons comes in hits photosystem one
maybe its antenna molecules through
resonance energy that excites the
electron it might directly hit the
chlorophyll in photosystem one and in
its reaction Center and then this gets
excited again this gets excited again
and so once again we have an electron
with a high potential that can go keep
going to from one molecule to another as
it gets more and more comfortable and
this releases energy that can drive the
proton pump and it eventually ends up in
the NADPH at a fairly high level of
energy still this this electron can
still be transferred to other things and
release energy and we'll see that when
we talk about the light independent
reactions now the whole point of me
showing you this is I wanted to kind of
depict graphically that the electron is
starting off at a pretty low energy
State the only way this happens is by
energy from light this would not happen
on its own going from a low energy state
to a higher energy state and I touched
on in the last videos if you have this
electron going here and it gets
transferred from one molecule to another
it gets excited again then keeps going
all the way eventually being accepted by
the nad plus to become NADPH and you
know the reason we're like where is that
H come from we could say well that H is
a proton it gets that electron and then
they merge together and you have NADPH
but either way but the question is what
replaces this electron and that's where
that amazing thing that I talked about
in the last video happens water gets
oxidized oxidizing is losing electrons
oil-rig so water gets oxidized by the
float by the the water ox the water
oxidation site on photosystem 2 and that
electron ends up and replaces but the
electron in the chlorophyll so you know
once again that's an amazing idea that
you're oxidizing oxygen so the net
effect of what happened what's happening
is
using energy using these this photon
energy right here to essentially strip
electrons off of water and as you know
when it's on water it's spending most of
its time on the oxygen so essentially
strip electrons off of oxygen and give
and put them in a higher energy state
and have them end up on NADPH and in the
process you know it had gone to an even
higher energy state and as it goes down
to NADPH you're pumping protons across
the membrane that we learned in the last
video through Keamy osmosis eventually
goes through the ATP synthase channel
turns around this part of the cut of
this protein complex or enzyme complex
and actually generates ATP ATP from ADP
and phosphate groups and in the electron
transport chain video what and when I
talk about cellular respiration I give a
visual concept about this actually might
happen how you could as these go through
you actually can jam together the ATP
and the ADP and so that's another
question in my head is you know we
talked about these electrons going from
one molecule to another but how does
that actually pump hydrogen through and
I'm just going to do a very gross
oversimplification I'm sure it's much
more complicated in actual plant cells
but you could imagine that you know we
have our we have our pheophytin right
here that's maybe that has that electron
on it right there maybe it has its
electron right there is a gross
oversimplification and then you have
your your plasto quinone your
plastoquinone right here that's the next
acceptor now maybe on this protein
complex right there
the point that wants to accept the
electron is is right there and let's say
that there's another point let's say
that there's another point on it that
can accept a hydrogen maybe it accepts a
hydrogen proton there so you can imagine
when it's on on this side of the
membrane a hydrogen can become attached
right there and this guy I mean will
want to be attracted to that so he'll
rotate he'll rotate around so you can
imagine this you
this is kind of a wheel this attraction
because he wants the electron wants to
go into a lower energy state right here
it'll rotate around that'll allow
essentially this hydrogen as it rotates
as this molecule as this protein rotates
around this hydrogen will be able to
cross the barrier and then once this guy
and that guy meet then the hydrogen will
be on the other side and so it can
freely go away again so that's at least
in my head in my head how I imagined a
electrons going from a higher energy
state to a lower energy State
how that can actually drive a reaction
remember the electrons want to do this
so they'll attract the different parts
of the molecules together and as those
molecules turn and rotate and move that
can help facilitate hydrogen going from
the stroma the outside of the thylakoid
to the inside of the thylakoid that'll
drive the chemiosmosis later on now
there's one other point I want to touch
on here everything I've just described
so far we started an electron in water
and obviously when when water loses its
elect its hydrogen's it loses both the
hydrogen protons and the electrons
associated with it you end up with just
water so you start off with hydrogen's
and then you end up with just two and
then the hydrogen protons the electron
got taken up by the chlorophyll when you
start off with that we've seen already
that you end up with the electron
sitting in NADPH the electron sitting
out here and NADPH so at some point you
have nad is is the final acceptor let me
do it in the right color you have any DP
plus is the final acceptor and it
becomes NADH and NADPH you can imagine
it accepts that maybe a hydrogen proton
from out here accepts the electron from
this electron transport chain in
photosynthesis and then becomes NADPH
and then that travels in the stroma
which is where the dark reactions occur
that actually produce the carbohydrate
but this idea of an electron going from
water to NADPH this is called this is
called non cyclic non
cyclic photo photo phosphorylation
phosphorylation it's called non cyclic
because you're not reusing the same
electrons over and over again the
electrons start off and depending how
you view it chlorophyll or the water and
they end up in the NADPH now there's
another type of photo phosphorylation
you might guess what it's called that's
called cyclic cyclic photo
phosphorylation you will see when we
study the dark cycles or the calvin
cycle or the dark reactions or the light
independent reaction that uses a lot of
ATP actually ATP it disrupt and
disproportion to the amount of any DPH
it uses it uses both but uses a ton of
ATP so cyclic phosphorylation
phosphorylation only produces ATP and
actually does not oxidize water so what
happens in that situation is this
electron after it gets activated or as
it gets after it gets excited in
photosystem 1 it's the electron it
eventually ends up instead of at NADPH
it ends up at photosystem 2 so instead
of this guy having to be replaced by
electrons from water this guy in cyclic
photophosphorylation ends up well maybe
I should do it from here ends up getting
replaced by the original electrons it
gets excited here goes from molecule to
molecule lower energy states hydrogen
gets pumped into the lumen it gets
excited again in photosystem 1 and then
it enters lower and lower energy states
but then ends up again in photosystem 2
that is cyclic photophosphorylation so
you can imagine in this situation since
we the electron never ends up at nad
plus you don't end up producing NADPH
and since you're replacing this electron
from from the photosynthesis or from the
electron transport chain directly you
don't have to strip the the electrons
off of the water so you're not going to
produce your oxygen so in this situation
so this non cyclic phosphorylation which
is kind of what most
photophosphorylation is what most people
associate with photophosphorylation
this produces Oh two and NADP NADPH and
of course it produces ATP while cyclic
phosphorylation only because it doesn't
have to strip electrons off of water and
the electrons don't end up at NADPH only
only produces ATP so I think we now have
a very good understanding hopefully of
the light reactions in photosynthesis
we're now ready to take the products of
this so let's remember what the products
were the products well you know the
oxygen just gets eliminated we don't
need the oxygen anymore but that goes
into the atmosphere and you and I can
breed that and we can use that for
cellular respiration but in the
photosynthesis context we've now
generated a bunch of ATP and now we have
a bunch of NADPH and we can use that in
conjunction with carbon dioxide in
conjunction with carbon dioxide to
produce actual carbohydrates in the
stroma right in the stroma outside the
thylakoids but we're still inside of the
chloroplast and I'll cover that in the
next video